ce soir d'eric zemmour & style qualifié
et bien pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
de résultats définitifs que je peux vous
demander des nouvelles de vos
circonscriptions du bureau viennent de
fermer ou le temps à ces carences ça
fait huit minutes qu'ils ont fermé on
attend patiemment avez-vous les
résultats hugo de l'élection à marseille
n'ont toujours pas de résultat ici à
marseille christelle dites nous tout
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas de green
résultats définitifs ce que je peux vous
demander des nouvelles dans votre
circonscription pour l'instant je n'en
ai pas encore réagi quand même pas de
définitif ensuite signer qui nous a
rejoint vous avez regardé hier les clés
et différentes chaînes quand vous avez
trouvé ça ah bah j'ai trouvé que à
chaque soirée électorale on ajoute du
vide au vide on ne tirait pas les aussi
de ce tribun non mais on voit bien que
les français se sont majoritairement pas
intéressé à cette élection législative
et on a vu des mecs et des nanas qui
sont censés être des restes politiques
qui ont sorti la sulfateuse qui ont su
rejouer des positions qui étaient tout à
fait factice et qui va en profiter pour
régler leurs comptes au lieu de parler
aux français d intéresser au second tour
c'est dommage alors pour animer la
soirée électorale hier sur france 2 il y
avait bien sûr anne sophie lapix et
laurent delahousse
regardez
laurent delahousse ils excellent mais
hier il avait il est en galère et il
n'est pas en forme on sait pas pourquoi
il a un peu galéré mais ce qui nous
regarde merci jean baptiste on va
prendre la direction de on va retrouver
la première ministre qui prend la parole
actuellement au qg l'air m et c'est
effectivement en sièges qu apparaît en
tête on va peut-être prendre la
direction justement du du qg de serge
cimino de cues et de jean luc mélenchon
avec serge cimino serre ges que vous
entendez pour voir cette première
réaction on voulait savoir également
l'ex ministre des sports roxana
maracineanu marrison signer à nous marie
signer à nous voilà c'est comme ça je me
suis jamais planté un avis faut que je
me plante ce soir
j'adore j'adore je dis la vérité voilà
je le kiffe de ouf je trouve qu'il est
ils utilisent pas assez sur france
animal anne sophie lapix dirais pas la
même chose voilà je trouve qu'elle est
c'est une canne à ste sont plus personne
ne veut y aller ils vont la dégager du
jt ou pas froisser les rumeurs en vrai
on va pas se mentir sous une pression ce
soir se ferait bien j'aimais bien avant
mais lâchez pas ou qu'elle allait partir
en cacahuète lac et parce qu'elle a sévi
des arêtes se révélèrent pour rien wells
a dirigé l'ird est évident non non et
non
rocard rien n'y a pas des repas non les
balais pas dû elle est pas dû être
ordinaire vous avez raison
je trouve qu'elle est en fait c'est à
chaque fois qu'elle reçoit un homme
politique il faut qu'il ya un manque de
respect je suis désolé mais moi je vois
là je trouve que c'est trop voilà on
peut rigoler ça mais c'est vrai et tout
on vénère on dirait que voilà et c'est
pas ça que tu vas voir tu vas tu vas
leur faire sortir des trucs il y en a un
qui a carrément a pris son résultat en
direct à la télévision sur le plateau
c'est guillaume pelletier de reconquête
qui était avant dans la biscotte
regardez
on additionne le rn les républicains
reconquête et les divers droite c'est 40
% des voix bien au delà de la gauche est
donnée à gauche et vous même dans votre
circonscription guillaume pelletier si
nos informations sont bonnes nous est
éliminée avec 14% des voix dans votre
alors question du du loir-et-cher
regardez moi j'ai bien sûr fois que
c'était toujours là la défaite on
l'avait anticipé moi j'ai choisi le
panache des convictions plutôt pleut le
confort de la carrière
je vous aimez ces débris kilari en
direct un il ya quelques mois y avait
pas une phrase qui se faisaient sans
amour dans la phrase et là ils sont
complètement mort zemmour a été nominé
sont tous éliminés c'est un carnage
l'avais je pense je sais pas si
reconquête peut s'en sortir en fait à
xaintrailles paraît que d'après mes
infos anne-sophie lapix tout sera là
l'année prochaine mais l'année prochaine
voilà ce serait peut-être sa dernière
saison au jt de 20h voit la petite info
voilà peut-être sa dernière saison là je
le donne je donne l'info la com com elle
arriva non mais c'est vrai il un des
grands perdants ces législatives c'est
qu'elles aient ou non mais elle elle est
reconduite l'année prochaine
je venais saison et avait fini je ne
sais pas pour l'instant de signe une
saison après et après mais qu'est ce que
j'en sais moi je passion qui agit pas
son attaché de presse - mais est
apparemment une saison de plus après il
ya des noms qui circulent caroline ont
notamment
alors l'un des grands perdants mais
qu'elle ne sera là qu'une saison est
peut-être au moins une peut-être oui
voilà
que va devenir reconquête comment
va-t-il rebondir nos journalistes ont
réussi à infiltrer la réunion de crise
qui a eu lieu ce matin après les
résultats de reconquête on en sait un
peu plus sur le parti regarde
en cause de présidentielle et des
législatives rollin dans les oufs
lezennes de la côte il faut acquérir
votre avis un jour enfin euros du coup
vous retrouvez notre cible serait
qu'elle tape et qui pour le soin d'y
résider s'écoute je propose les
angliches j'écoute ils ont foutu la
merde au stade de france et ils ont
obligé baba à passer sous le tonique et
notre baba adorable généreux incapable
de faire une telle chose ou la torre bas
par
[Musique]
dessus ce sont les mamelles bravo 11 il
faut par là dessus c'est bon moi j'ai
une autre idée qui aujourd'hui fait peur
aux français
le jugement
relative sécurité oui la mixité oui
les étrangers et non tout ça
c'est la même chose
regarder ton émotions de trail tu vois
bien que
je parle voilà htm alors moi aussi cette
boue il vient après aujourd'hui les
american staff en train de les mélanger
les uns avec les autres il va sauter un
truc mais tu ne peux pas aller à la
mairie pour le fait que c'est un chien
qui ne risquez rien me collard ça nous
fait marrer voilà qui n'a remarqué ça te
fais ma recette fait mario doucette fait
mari ne vous faites plus boulos par un
american staff votez le z
pour eric zemmour a traduit florin en
tout cas ça va être dur à remonter parce
que je tenais à revenir dans les médias
peut-être bien évidemment que ça reste
un personnage médiatique dans les
difficultés sais ce qu'il est capable
aujourd'hui d'installer son personnage
politique localement territorialement
qui est une base pour faire de la
politique au niveau national on a vu que
ce pari il est plutôt ratée pour lui et
ses lieutenants hier alors il ya des
défaites aussi qui a fait énormément
parler celle de jean michel blanquer a
lancé un mini de l'éducation le pauvre
était persuadé d'être victime d'un
complot à tel point qu'ils pensent être
devenu l'ennemi public numéro un mesrine
c'est vrai qu'en regardant de plus près
ses faits et gestes tout porte à croire
qu'ils aient le nouveau mesrine
quand j'ai dénoncé cette extrême gauche
aux dominos taris tu sais je suis devenu
l'ennemi public numéro un
est ce que vous diriez que cette annonce
dangereux
pour coiffer tout ça
vous avez des projets
avec son vélo depuis plusieurs années je
suscite beaucoup d' attaques
dans ses articles vraiment beaucoup de
choses ces peaux de lapins comme on dit
chez moi c'est quoi ces conneries
comment pensez vous allez payer
[Musique]
qui n'est toujours avoir le dernier mot
qui se retrouvent toujours tout seul je
suis devenu l'ennemi public numéro un
blanc caire l'ennemi public numéro 1
pour faire une élection si jamais facile
mais qu'en plus vous êtes sur un plateau
coups et combos défoncé que vous avez
perdu c'est clairement extrêmement
passera c'est france 2 qui avait décidé
d'être présents des gros bat avec les
perdants hier soir regardez
est ce que à force de ne pas faire
campagne le point dans un public dépasse
en face d'un échec ce soir richard
ferrand bonsoir est ce qu'il ya eu un
problème de campagne un peu molle vous
avez été absent blues avaient disparu
que s'est il passé quelle était votre
stratégie on a compris la stratégie
mélenchon et les vôtres bonsoir jean
michel blanquer remercie d'être avec
nous ce soir un soir de défaite vous
n'êtes plus ministre de l'éducation
nationale vous aviez fait le choix d'où
vous lancer dans cette campagne risque
et elle est très risqué au point de ne
pas être qualifié pour le second tour
qu'elle ait de grèves autre déception ce
soir
[Rires]
alors c'est dur non mais sérieux c'est
normal bon après c'est quoi ils font là
il se prépare à ça il dit voilà on va
aller on va appeler on va appeler les
bousculer soir mais je pense qu'il faut
mesurer à quel point c'est difficile on
va pas les plaindre mais il faut mesurer
à quel point c'est dur d'encaisser les
chèques personnels ça demandait quand
même beaucoup d'efforts souvent ils se
sont enfin ils n'ont pas consacré de
temps à leur famille et à leurs amis les
stars pour cette campagne ils y ont
souvent laissé pas mal de fric l'avait
fait le résultat en plus à titre perso
ils doivent défendre la position de leur
parti avec lesquels d'ailleurs ils ne
peuvent ne pas être d'accord résultat ça
donne des positions pas du tout sincère
ça convainc personne et cette soirée
électorale ne sert pas à grand-chose
d'autre qu'aux règlements de comptes
auxquels on assiste régulièrement sur
les plateaux à ces moments là alors
comme à chaque élection on a eu droit à
notre spectacle préféré sur les plateaux
télé le rds le rachida dati show
formation d'habitude l'ancien ministre
de la justice était très en forme ont
gardé
dans ta gueule
si un candidat l air est éliminé les
résultats
arrivent et le tas vient très fort
ancrage dans les airs et rive nord
aurait dû aurait dû être nava combien la
victime l'ancien gunner renvoie la ville
à moins de 4,8 à 12 ça fait quoi trois
fois plus gros ils sont nos forces pour
rebâtir la droite franck s'attendait
alors vous imaginez rachida dati la
vieille eric zemmour base
je ne sais pas la question dan care est
totalement pertinente pourquoi pas la
réponse est dans la question quel est le
bilan c'est de dire qu'on aura tous le
même chargeur de téléphone pour tous les
téléphones c'est ce que j'ai retenu
parce que le président la république l'a
twitté voilà le bilan de la présence
française j'écris j'ai vraiment un
sentiment de maped show la voyez un
miroir de limoges
s'il vous plaît rachida vers city ne
ferait mieux de baisser d'un ton parce
qu'on verra au deuxième tour
j'adore j'adore je l'adoré c'est la
meilleure je me regarde les soirées
électorales que pour voir les punchline
de rachida dati c'est une icône est là
cette âme de terrain elle est partie de
rien et je trouve que ça se voit dans sa
façon de faire de la politique je la
donne je l'adorais la diff on sait que
les bottines ottaway elle était dans les
cordes à ses débuts elle n'était pas
bien mais là mystère de mr x la
présidentielle aussi aller me défoncer
je sais mais je crois qu'elle est pas
fan des lettres sur chez nous servir ils
ont invité une fine et figure de la
gauche que l'on connaît bien ici raquel
garrido elle est candidate est bien
placé dans la 5e circonscription de
seine saint denis mais hier soir et
voulait parler tout autre chose à
voulait parler à faire un hommage à
benjamin castaldi
xavier a eu des mots assez vulgaire à
l'endroit de stanislas très sympathique
de vous en exclu
vous n'arrêtez pas non plus la nuit dans
votre lit
[Applaudissements]
laquelle tu fais ce que tu veux bacheri
bien entendu on verra pas vérifié il y
en a qui aurait préféré très dur hier
soir c'est gabriel attal regardez on
peut le lire clairement ils se déchirent
sur leurs gardes entre les socialistes
mondialistes des manèges macro et les
communistes de madame automne monsieur
mélenchon est bien l'hémicycle va être
archi dominé probablement rendez vous
compte par 500 députés de gauche et
d'extrême gauche regardez ont réussi les
mélenchonistes en unissant les forces de
gauche
est un des éléments le plus important ce
soir électorat la télé c'est bien sûr la
technique tout doit être prêt les duplex
eux sont l'animation c'est pour ça qu'on
en fait jamais sur celui dont des portes
voilà surtout au niveau de l'animation
et sur france 2 hier soir
les gars étaient pas prêts pour garder
cela peut peser sur le scrutin
on a un petit problème de son me
semble-t-il regarder notamment l'ancien
ministre de l'écologie ouais peut-être
barbara pompili ya si on peut l'envoyer
en régie
la voilà le candidat est effectivement
je ne sais pas de quelle circonscription
il s'agit et on va tout de suite prendre
des nouvelles de la première ministre
elisabeth bornes on retrouve alors on va
peut-être d'abord passer par dans l'est
que mélenchon qui va prendre la parole
alors est-ce qu'on attend jean luc
mélenchon on va laisser pour la parole
est ensuite à banon il est parti dit
bonjour à quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]